you guys want to know what i eat in a
day so here it is jojo let's talk about
it starting off before i work out with a
bar and some pre-workout i'm not sure
what kind of bar that is but i would
definitely look for one that has some
energizing carbs in there for
pre-workout after my workout i had a
breakfast burrito from air one some
strawberries and mangoes and of course a
green juice this burrito was so good it
had eggs spinach mushroom this post
workout looks amazing burritos are
inherently well balanced i love that
we're getting some protein in there we
got some carbohydrates probably some
healthy fats as well and we got some
fruit in there to replenish those
glycogen stores and some green juice in
there for extra micronutrients looks
like a great way to recover after a
workout this is me drinking some water i
drink a ton of water three or four of
these bottles a day we love a hydrated
queen but of course i want i want to
know that there's not a one size fits
all amount for how much water you should
be drinking the old eight eight ounce
glasses a day of water is an outdated
recommendation and it's just a
generalization so pay attention to your
body and drink when you're thirsty i
wanted a salad so we had some leftovers
from salads we made the other day so i
just did some eggs some little mini
cucumbers some peas some ranch and i
mixed it all up boo yeah i wanted some
raisin toast put a little bit of butter
on it and call it good had some annie's
bunnies had some more raisin bread had a
mandarin orange and dried one this lunch
is bomb we've got lots of fiber rich
produce here we got protein in the egg
we've got carbs in the fruit and the
toast and we got some fat from the
dressing and the toast as well looks
like a very satisfying lunch then at the
airport i had some noodles and an apple
they were both so yummy the apple was so
juicy and good some more water had a
little banana then i got on my flight
had some grapes and cheese a turkey
sandwich and called it a day i love that
even at the airport she managed to find
some produce just to bump up the satiety
factor and get some extra fiber in there
that late night sandwich looks awesome
we got carbs we got fat we got protein
and she also managed to get in some
extra fruit as well looks like an
amazing and non-restrictive day and
judging by the comments i know that a
lot of you appreciate seeing a woman eat
a non-restrictive amount of food so
thanks jojo for sharing your day i look
forward to seeing more